una y otra vez me han preguntado estás
listo
yo listo
armado así
como saben que estoy armado hoy ya vi
sus esculturas que están afuera ya vi lo
que trajiste
y en eso me he convertido
un artista
que dispara
un artista que transforma
el día de hoy tengo solamente un
objetivo
mi objetivo es dispararles a ustedes
dicen que estoy preparado
porque desde que entre ustedes me han
estado disparando
miradas
pensamientos sentimientos
como saben
porque se siente
se vive como impacta eso a cada uno de
nosotros
este objetivo de dispararles a ustedes
solamente es con una pregunta una
pregunta que me ha dejado huella hace
muchos años y ha construido todo un
diálogo a través de estos años
es por eso que la huella para mí es
trascendental es un código que permite
hablar
transformar
para qué
para hablar sobre un código
único irrepetible cada uno de nosotros
traemos un código tenemos una
información que hace
que pueda ser trascendental en cada uno
de nosotros hoy en día
más o menos para dar un comparativo
en esta estructura soy yo son 80 kilos
de masa corporal
qué equivale a cada uno de los monitos
son 162 monitos multiplicados
correspondería a lo que son 13 toneladas
de armas
actualmente tengo posición 13 toneladas
de armas transformándolos en diferentes
cosas
una escultura otra escultura que se
encuentra valentino valentina y santiago
son dos obras
que fueron petición por parte de la
sedena secretaría defensa nacional son
las personas entidades que me han
entregado con responsabilidad para
poderlas transformar y sobre todo
generar un diálogo de cultura de paz
sonará un poco contradictorio un mucho
eso dependerá de cada uno de ustedes lo
que sí en mi diálogo es que se necesita
empezar a transformar desde un poco más
abajo
tengo en posición 20 mil 75 juguetes
bélicos
en donde están esperando que diferentes
personas como ustedes ahí es 1er
disparo quien de ustedes les interesa
transformar todos esos juguetes para
hacer juguetes de cultura de paz
esta diapositiva va enfocado a una
filosofía esencial
llevo años estudiando esa filosofía en
donde
se habla de la parte física se habla de
la parte espiritual sentimental y mental
el disparo que quiero hacer que es la
pregunta clave
de esta charla es el objetivo es llegar
a ustedes y posiblemente puede llegar a
penetrar de tal forma que les deje
huella
solamente quiero hacer una pregunta
bueno álvaro pues ya si es mucho decir y
decir cuál es esa pregunta
cuál será una pregunta que llevo años
que me ha dejado huella
para hablar de eso se necesita generar
de un contenido y una experiencia de una
persona que me dijo hoy álvaro
sabías que las armas mienten
si tú no sabes si un arma está cargada
de balas
cuando sabes que sucede es cuando te
enteras
de la bala la bala es la que dice la
verdad
pero si abrimos una bala que es lo que
contiene esta bala que contiene
contiene una carencia de algo de igual
forma como entidad nosotros nos
proyectamos ante la vida buscando formas
para apoyar para poder llegar y aflorar
e impactar en cada uno de nosotros ya
sea de manera física sentimental mental
o espiritual
ese contenido la c es la carencia
esa carencia que en potencia se hace una
necesidad necesidad en movimiento
movimiento
en emoción emoción sentimiento
sentimiento discernimiento se
discernimiento para poder elegir
la siguiente pregunta
cuál sería esa siguiente pregunta
cuál es tu más profundo deseo
esa pregunta
me interesa que ustedes disparen con más
preguntas o con más respuestas
los espero afuera
los espero en redes sociales los espero
en cualquier momento para estar listos y
armados porque se necesita un méxico que
deje huella y que pueda impactar mi
diálogo es a través del arte me expreso
a través de las esculturas en la
transformación de ellas ustedes ignoro
si es a través del pensamiento si es a
través de la forma de hablar del sentido
de actuar
los invito
a convivir a través de preguntas a
través de un diálogo para poder dejar
una huella gracias
[Aplausos]